♪ In the arms of the angels ♪
- We're all familiar with
the saddest ad of all time.
But did you know that it helped raise
over $30 million for the ASPCA?
(light music)
Hey, Nahre.
- Hey, LA, what's up?
(laughter)
- Okay, so, I was watching the
sad animal commercial
with Sarah McLachlan.
In the arms of an angel.
And it's the saddest thing ever.
How did they make that commercial so sad?
How did they get that effect?
I know it's complicated, but
could you explain the basics
of what makes a song sound sad to us?
- You know, I think
that's just a topic where
songwriters are really so
far ahead of scientists
that I feel hesitant to
dispense any suggestions.
- So there are many techniques that
songwriters use to make a song sound sad.
Although with all of these techniques,
there are plenty of exceptions.
Stereotypically speaking,
people associate major chords
with happiness and minor
chords with sadness.
But oftentimes this isn't the case.
For example, "Angel" by Sarah McLachlan
is in the key of D flat major.
♪ In the arms of the angel ♪
♪ Fly away from here. ♪
- On the other hand, there plenty of
party anthems written in the minor key,
and they definitely don't sound sad.
♪ Every day I'm shuffling ♪
♪ Party rockers in the house tonight ♪
♪ We just wanna see ya shake that ♪
- But still here are some
ingredients that can help
you write a sad song, including
the use of minor chords.
Western music is generally based on
the relationship between
the following chords.
Here it is in C major.
(plays piano)
Now in C minor.
Let's take the C minor chord
in its most basic form.
It's comprised of three
notes, C, E flat, and G.
If I play a note that it
is not part of this chord,
it's called a non chord tone.
For example, F is not a
part of these three notes.
(plays piano)
Now if I play this F and
I bring it back to one of
the chord tones, in this case, E flat.
(plays piano)
This movement is called an appoggiatura.
Applied to the previous chord progression,
they sound like this.
(plays piano)
Let's now add some more notes
to create descending lines.
This type of movement downwards tends
to create a sense of longing.
(plays piano)
Repeated notes and figures can also
create a more somber effect.
For example, let's compare this figure.
(plays piano)
To this one.
Now, of course a lot of the
emotional effects that come from
these notes depend on the
way that you play them.
(plays piano)
- One of the main ingredients for
a sad song would be a slow tempo.
- One thing people think
about has to do with
how we move and speak when we're sad.
And this idea that music kind of borrows
or mimics those characteristics.
So if you think about what
it would sound like if I was
talking to you and I was really sad.
(laughter)
Right?
I might slow down, my
voice might get lower.
And so all these kinds of things
that you might do musically
when you're trying to express sadness.
- If you were to speed up the song "Angel"
by Sarah McLachlan, it
wouldn't sound very sad at all.
♪ In the arms of the
angel fly away from here ♪
♪ From this dark cold hotel room ♪
♪ And the endlessness that you feel ♪
- So, "Angel" has a slow
tempo, and there are
some repeated notes and chord movements
that create some tension,
but overall I couldn't
find that many sad song
techniques used in the song.
So I wonder, is the commercial sad
because of the song itself, or because of
the visuals that go along with it?
- There are lots of
studies in music perception
that ask exactly that kind of question.
And the way they'll ask
it is they'll play people
just the song and then
they'll show other people
just the imagery, just the sad dogs.
And they'll show other
people the whole commercial
and get people to rate how sad it seems.
And usually the type of
thing that research finds
is that those visual images are really
seeping into the sounds themselves.
You feel like you're
responding to the music,
but it's really quite
impactfully shaped by the imagery
you're seeing while you're listening.
And not only for that
hearing, but much later.
So you could hear that song, you know,
years later when you've
forgotten the sad dogs,
like, you don't remember overtly the dogs.
However, you know, they've
left their mark, in the sense
that the song continues to
sound really devastating to you.
- Is there something
that happens to the brain
when you're processing
these types of emotions,
when you're listening to something sad?
- [Jonna] There's something
called mirror neurons
or the mirror system in the brain.
So these are basically neurons
in the brain that are active
both when are observing
another person carrying out
an action, such as grasping
an apple, for example,
and when ourselves are grasping an apple.
So basically these are
neurons that help us
understand the actions
of others by actually
stimulating them internally,
so as if we ourselves
were carrying out that same action.
This is also related to
a phenomenon called emotional contagion.
For example, if we are speaking
with someone who is sad,
we start to mimic or imitate,
mirror their sad facial
expressions and their posture,
and we might ourselves kind of
start feeling sad as a result.
- And can this happen when
you're listening to music?
Can you mirror what's happening
in the music, and, say that
I'm happy today and I listened
to something that's sad.
Can I all of a sudden turn sad
because I'm mirroring these emotions?
- We don't really have any
solid evidence on it yet,
but there are quite a
lot of theoretical papers
proposing that this is probably
what might be happening
while are listening to sad
music as well, that our brain
is engaged in this sort of mirroring.
- So, we thought it could
be fun if we tried to make
the music psychologist
sad by putting all of
our sad ingredients
into one original song.
And of course, we couldn't forget
the saddest ingredient
of all: homeless animals.
(sad music)
- First of all there's this
sort of lamenting pattern,
this very old kind of pattern
that's like a sigh, right?
And there's also this kind of
stasis, right, in that excerpt
where it feels like you're kind of stuck
and that's a very kind
of common experience
during sadness or depression, right?
That you can't kind of move beyond it.
I guess that's probably, you
know, not as helpful to you,
but it's very helpful to me,
to like listen to, you know,
what people do when they're
writing sad music, sure.
♪ You're in the arms of the angels ♪
- Hi, I'm Nahre Sol.
Please say you'll
subscribe to Sound Field.
We need your help.
Right now, comment and
tell us what you think
the saddest song in the world is,
and let us know what you think of ours.
And remember, adopt, don't shop.